hello everybody my name is mark of iron
if you didn't know already I'm kind of
sick but I'm hopped up on about ten
different types of cold medication so I
wanted to play a video game here called
xcv B and I played it a little bit as
far as I can tell Hey it makes no
goddamn sense at all it's xcv B okay so
this is really hard to explain X and C
change the orientation of your character
and b and b change the direction that
you're going so if i press or if i'm in
that orientation and press b up I'm
going i'll go right into the wall but if
i okay X changes your X X off screwed
you know what forget it you're not gonna
understand it anyway you're not gonna
play this game I'm just gonna play it
until I get it okay you go that way you
press B to go X or Y and then B Fahd
side you'll be to go X or Y and then you
press V to go up or down but you gotta
be you gotta be oriented in the correct
you gotta be oriented in the correct
direction to be able to go that way so
if you got a 5 god mother up get in the
mother flipping right way okay we're
going we're going okay we're okay we got
to go V and then we got a switch to
being know the ax or b XC god I don't
know why I chose to play this game but
for some reason it called to me this
said oh this is B YouTube freaking gold
right here
oh man everyone wants to see me play
this game cuz it'll be so freakin fine
other buttons how you make okay you may
you might be looking at this and be like
oh what's the big deal
fun got it
what's the big deal oh it's not a big
problem oh yes it actually is because
you don't understand okay that way there
we go okay this is a little Quarian take
Gordon
whatever I'm going screw it you don't
care you care about me you don't care
about what I have to go through there we
go okay I'm starting to get it once you
get a hang of it it gets a little bit
easier okay it's just a little bit
easier so we're just gonna go along till
we can get it there we go see just fine
so a mister doesn't get too complicated
there why is that multicolor down oh
good god this is not good for me
not right now holy crap not that way
okay so we got to go down now and then
we go to the bottom oh my god I'm
tripping balls either okay you got to be
clear with me guys did this actually go
multicolored or should I have not taken
that many bills I don't care either way
let's just move forward I gotta put an
epilepsy warning at the beginning of
this video
god damn it okay whatever just um just
do what I want you to do do what I want
you to do okay it's okay you know what I
don't care it's fine
I got this okay
it's the X&Y why can't I remember this I
just I can't friggin it's down fee is
goddamn down I'm trying to think about
how I'm gonna orient myself when I do
that that's okay you know what it's
alright
nothing freakin right way until you go
until you get it gone get it do it there
we go go down and flip and Boosh yeah
don't know why that was so freaking hard
oh my god this is gonna be oh it's a
puzzle is it are you doing to me okay
wait hang on
flip that way go up but that would go
that way oh this is harder than it looks
okay I'm not bad this game is hard okay
it's like freaking co-op if it was on
drugs and malaria I don't
I don't even know what I'm talking about
right now just give me a second to
coordinate my own goddamn self
so that Fahd so that I can figure out
what I'm gonna do with my life because
apparently this is all I'm resorting to
even when I'm freaking sick I don't get
a break up and then right there we go oh
okay
so now we're on the green level which
means that we're gonna go into a trippy
insane place where it's my favorite
color but no one gives a [ __ ]
that's right green is my favorite color
okay down oh what's that wrong oh that
not good enough for you not healthy it's
not healthy behavior I would think that
if anyone saw me right now they would
probably think that I'm going out of my
mind oh wait
millions of people thousands I'm not
that popular millions of thousands of
people I didn't even come close to
hitting that wall freaking communist I
don't even know that lease is good cuz I
don't know rainbows and whatnot it
should be happy fun times but it's not
it isn't I'm just too aggravated I'm too
out of my mom just keep calm but
apparently it's not okay it's never
gonna be okay because my life is a
freakin lie just like the cake is a god
damn there we go there we go get it
again oh oh how do I go all right
I might even tell the guy I spit on my
screen no no my good old IPS monitor
Fraga Freya way up but no why did you go
up god damn it
this is so confusing you do not
understand
a freaking confusing this is it's like
backwards and upside down and like the
worst version is Hitler it is this is
literally this is like what Hitler's
brain must have been like because this
goddamned piece of communist
rainbow-colored son of a [ __ ] not
backwards okay that way flip down man I
just don't have enough insults in my
brain to comment oh god I wasn't even
close it wasn't even freakin near it but
just a son of a [ __ ] I'm gonna lose my
[ __ ] mind I'm gonna freak out I'm
already freaking out you know no the
other ways sort of a bit don't ask why
I'm twitching so god damn much I don't
even know freak up some people god I
push the words whatever you know what
that's the wrong way Jack wad get this
the correct orientation because it's a
frickin [ __ ] son of a mother-of-pearl
I'm not gonna curse for the rest of the
thing because some people say that
Christie much and this game is not good
for my blood pressure
God dang it dang it dingus pingas pingas
pingas that's up and down you stupid my
fingers they don't work they don't
frickin work god it's four buttons it's
warm or freakin buttons it's not working
okay down I go to the left and down and
then I go down the left
I'm just I'm just I'm just
yo you know I'm gonna get through this
level cuz goddamn green level maybe I
could go down there maybe I was supposed
to go down there maybe you was just
lying to me that I couldn't go down
there maybe at the son of a [ __ ] oh
wait
oh god you me father she saw I wanna
just get I just saw Pacific Rim you went
in there before I know that I was there
everybody saw you can't hide the
internet knows ah okay here we go again
the flashing colors if everyone hasn't
had a seizure already it's about to have
yeah I was already getting good it the
other way let's just go that way
and that'll be fine and then I'll be
able to go home sleep or I will be able
to sleep for 10 jillion hours go down
what do I know remember what the down
and up buttons you dirty rat
you're gonna find yourself living with a
damn fishes rainbow trout fish humor
hope everyone appreciates my highbrow
joke watch I don't even gonna look at
the screen it's gonna look at you guys I
bet I do better for some strange reason
down don't get it watch oh my God why is
it so freakin hard that's what she said
I can't lose my mind now got that
vertical okay I just gotta calm down
can't calm down it taking like ten pills
of goddamn dayquil God you don't even
know how hell drugs just random drugs
just shoot up into by up Farva Blatz son
of a match god I'm an earl yeah Tim okay
hell
I mean frickin hell whatever I'm trying
to find other creative things besides
Kurt's words to say but it's not going
so well
Oh God
Pratt solana do sambal zone II I want
pastrami sorry you know what I'm gonna
give this one last try if I don't get it
I'm gonna lose my mind
and then I'm frickin gonna go yeah all
right I'm gonna try it forever until I
get it how about that how about that I'm
I swear to god I'm making the whole like
sweating it's not good for me this is
not good for anyone there's it not
entertaining this is not God does
actually it's probably like YouTube gold
ten million views automatically gia yeah
I'm gonna get so many subs from this
view video whatever
let's make it in the gear up just get in
the hole that's one it's a tight fit
it's enough
yeah